bitcoin mining is on an absolute tear in
terms of the hash rate over the last
five years or so uh there's all sorts of
geopolitics that play into it just walk
me through your analysis of how big is
this thing how important is the actual
network and the hash rate and then any
of the geopolitical stuff that you see
yeah so there's a lot to unpack with
with that right there but when it comes
to bitcoin's hash rate the growth of
bitcoin's hash rate is incredibly
important because obviously as a as an
asset class we want to see it continue
to succeed and be secure so we need more
machines on the network to to further
that the one thing i'll say is it's
incredibly resilient right we saw china
basically cut half of bitcoin's hash
rate off the network in june
and there was there wasn't a there
wasn't a hitch in the getty up when it
comes to bitcoin everything still ran
just as it should block times continued
on it was a great period of
profitability for miners and now we're
starting to see the hash rate climb back
up as these machines go online in
different areas but the cool thing about
mining is we never know what country is
going to go wacky right you have
china that banned bitcoin then you have
russia who started to constrict the the
energy supply to kazakhstan so
kazakhstan's hash rate started to fall
off so we're seeing all of these
different geopolitical things that are
leading to increased profitability for
any miners that are plugged in
specifically those in north america that
have continued to benefit from the
support that they've gotten from
different states like texas and kentucky
that have really fostered the growth of
mining within the within the us how much
of this went from people were doing on
their laptops to hey i got one or two
you know s9s or whatever kind of plugged
away in a
closet to then it became like more
professionalized today because it seems
like uh there's really big players now
and we kind of sort of saw that
beginning in china was the first time
with bit main and some of these players
where i was like whoa that's a big
facility yeah now it feels like this is
happening all over the world and people
have woken up to the idea of like i can
literally just sell this energy for a
very very profitable margin like talk
about the sophistication today versus
maybe a couple years ago well i mean now
it's now it's an actual business that
you can plan on right before i think
there was still just a lot of
speculation around whether or not
bitcoin would succeed you had the real
believers who continue to scale up their
operations and those are the guys and
gals that went from
laptops to gpus to fpgas to asics and
then focused on you know increasing the
amount of machines that they had online
but now what's happening is you have
people that have large amounts of
capital that are just entering the space
and they're they're you know they're bum
rushing the bit mains of the world to
get as many machines as they can because
they already have access to capital
markets you look at some of these
companies that were already publicly
traded and then just pivoted into
bitcoin mining basically and they have
access to hundreds of millions of
dollars they're able to get up and
running very quickly and take a
substantial amount of that hash rate and
i mean we've seen their stock prices
appreciate accordingly because of how
fast they were able to deploy and when
you think about these companies uh
historically they've essentially
self-funded from the entrepreneur or a
very small group of investors they mined
bitcoin then they had to sell the
bitcoin uh usually a majority of it to
be able to fund operations moving
forward if they got into a bear market
they didn't have capital to kind of
weather the storm we got into the whole
you know death mining spiral concern the
whole thing um and usually at the bottom
of the bear market people had to tap out
right you got you got below some price
and just hey i can't operate anymore i
gotta shut down how has the capital
markets changed for minors over the
years as well it seems like now people
are very well capitalized they've got
access to debt markets equity markets
and and people on the investment side
have woken up to this as well which
makes it much better business at the
same time of course i mean when you
think about the amount of capital that's
available in the united states
especially right now that's just looking
for a home it needs to find yield
somewhere right you talk about all the
time on the show if you don't put your
capital to work it's going to leave you
you know and now you have access to
those markets here in the states all of
these financial products that are
available allow miners to not have to
sell their bitcoin in order to to
increase their operations they can take
a loan out on the value of their asics
and then just buy more asics increase
their hash rate increase their
profitability and that's what we're
really seeing is a trend now you did
have a situation where what was it in
march of last year of 2020 where we had
that black swan event where bitcoin
crashed because of the financial
services that were available and you had
a mass liquidation event of a lot of
miners in china which led to bitcoin's
price crash but since then you've seen
a maturity in the space that's allowed
people to more more accurately plan
to avoid those kinds of situations now
and when you start to think about uh the
average person they're not going to go
raise hundreds of millions of dollars
and go build you know rockdale texas the
big facility uh they're not gonna try to
go figure out how do i buy discounted
miners from somebody shutting down in
china and move it to my home country
they're like dude i just want to play i
just want to play right i just like get
me in the game i think that's where
compass comes in right and you've got a
couple of different products maybe walk
us through your business in terms of
what is the product suite look like if
somebody wants to get into the mining
game yeah so when we first started our
whole idea was we wanted to be this
airbnb for bitcoin miners give them an
easy place to source their machines an
easy place to host them at a verified
facility where they could feel
comfortable that they weren't going to
get scammed and someone was going to run
off their with their hardware they'd
still get that bitcoin directly to their
wallet and we've really just built up uh
that product offering which is
essentially just a bundle where we sell
one asic with a 12-month hosting
contract it allows you to get all of
your bitcoin directly to your wallet you
just pay for power every month we also
sell miners to people who want to mine
at home there are a lot of people right
now who have
really taken on this idea of mining kyc
free bitcoin and the only way you can
really do that is to mine at your house
so now there are people who are
purchasing machines through compass we
ship them directly to their door
and then they'll work with some of these
consultants that are out there to you
know retrofit their home to be able to
take on these asics so these are really
the two main products and we do a lot of
sales for institutions as well funds and
family offices that want to get into
their own mining facilities they don't
want to host with someone else they want
to achieve that cheaper power price so
they'll come to compass and they'll buy
you know a thousand to five thousand
machines and then they'll build out
their own facility
can you break down in terms of which is
the more popular product and like how do
you think about managing your business
in terms of do you do more sales and
eventually you'll build out more kind of
self-hosting is it more self-hosting and
sales is uh kind of a growing part how
do you think about the difference so our
focus is retail right everything else
that happens is a benefit like we take
that as a bonus but really our focus is
helping people that want to get one to
five miners buy those machines and get
them hosted at a facility around the
country you know for this year we've
basically helped
put about 45 megawatts of hosted
capacity online for retail miners it's
about 95 of our business but moving into
next year we've actually already secured
280 megawatts that's going to be
available for retail miners these people
that are buying one to five machines
hosted at facilities around the us and
canada we also have facilities coming
online in norway paraguay and we're
looking at peru